northwest isn't having it with mom kim
kardashian it's like her world
another day another kardashian tick tock
moment kim tries to film a carpool
sing-along but per usual north speaks
her mind
[Music]
we're guessing nine-year-old north is
screaming because she wasn't feeling
those takes singing a bruno mars kid
north has a
private tick tock account so we do uh
lots of tick tocks together she puts
them in drafts sometimes north will see
me scrolling on my phone and say oh you
posted that of me
you know singing with my friends or
whatever i'll post and you know so
you learn boundaries
kim had better luck in april when
northey belted out the lyrics to a song
about a different bruno
[Music]
no no
[Music]
yep north is all about encanto and gave
us a pretty solid performance singing
along to the disney bop with her gal pal
[Music]
but let's be real north snapping at kim
in the car is hardly the first time she
shared her brutally honest opinions
last month she called out the paparazzi
for taking her picks during paris
fashion week
[Music]
and if that message wasn't loud enough
how's this north roasting kim for her
instagram voice
why do i talk different for what guys so
today i got this new mask and these
small bronzers i got this is that what
you is that what i say is that what i
sound like she definitely has kanye's
outgoing personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or
who it might have
so yeah no surprise that she's letting
kim know exactly what's on her mind
[Music]
you